لم تعتدي العاصمه السودانيه مثل كثير من
مدن البلاد على هذا النوع من القتال في
شوارعها ولم يكن نظامها الصحي من النوع
المؤهل لمواجهه انواع الحرب في الاصل وكما
في كل الحروب يكون المدنيون اول من يدفع
اثمانها الباهظه اطفال في عمر الزهور
وجدوا وجبه طعام لكنهم افتقدوا جرعه دواء
تعينهم على مواجهه امراض مستعصيه
يعني
الجرعه قديمه
لاي حاجه
[موسيقى]
ومنذ ان اندلع القتال في الخرطوم بدات
مستشفياتها تتداعى سريعا اكان ذلك بسبب
المواجهات المسلحه ام بسبب فقدان الموارد
الطبيه الاساسيه اخر معطيات نقابه اطباء
السودان رسمت صوره قاطمه لحال المستشفيات
في الخرطوم والولايات المتاخمه لمناطق
الاشتباك وقد خرج من الخدمه 52 مستشفى من
اصل اربعه وسبعين تسعه مستشفيات تم قصفها
وتسعه عشر تعرضت للاخلاء القصري ما تبقى
من مستشفيات عامله لا يتعدى 22 وبعضها
يقدم خدمه الاسعافات الاوليه فقط اطباء
السودان دقوا ناقوس الخطر مرارا وتكرارا
واجمعوا على ان الوضع كارثي بكل ما للكلمه
من معنى بالاضافه للقصف المستشفيات برضو
من اليوم الاول الاسقاط والقوادر الصحيه
لعدم وجود الامان في الاضافه لضعرض حياتهم
من الخطر
قبل ان تبدا المواجهات المسلحه لم يكن حال
السودانيين على افضل حال فبرنامج الاغذيه
العالمي نبهها من ان نحو ثلث سكان السودان
يعانون من الجوع وبناء عليه حذر من ان
يؤدي استمرار العنف الى الالقاء بملايين
اخرين في دائره المجاعه لا احد يدري
بالضبط متى يمكن ان تنتهي المعارك الجاريه
في السودان لكن الاكيد ان المدنيين العزل
سيكونون الاكثر تضررا منها